all right thank you guys I am here with
luuka I got so much to talk to you about
but first things first you went and got
that game ball who did you get that game
ball for Luca om his first points in the
NBA pretty awesome stuff all right you
guys are seven and two off to a great
start what do you attribute this start
to I mean today uh we had to start with
the face you know our face was great
today and we were guarding too so it was
you know we played a a very complete
game everybody we're talking team stuff
let's talk individual stuff you had 44
points you only missed four shots Kyrie
who just did that had 27 points in 28
minutes it seems to really be working
out with you two guys playing together
well offensively yeah and I keep saying
you know not just it's not just us to
you know we get stops uh DJ has been
great for us so but everybody contribute
so it's not just two two of us uh
everybody help us so uh when we play
good it's it's there you know everybody
else help us doing that so it's like I
say it's everybody else it's really fun
to watch and finally this is the second
inseason Tournament game for you guys
does it give you a little extra juice to
know that you're playing against these
teams in your group and what that might
mean yeah I mean every game matters I
know especially in the inseason
tournament uh you're not get you're not
getting 82 games so you got to win uh
every game possible uh but you know
we're just trying to win every game tell
Max I'm sorry for holding you up thank
you L you no worries all right that's
Luca
donic